[Music]
you're the tricky thing about predicting
music for next year so unlike TV and
movies those dates are set so well in
advance we know when they're coming
music album release dates are a little
bit of a mystery so I'm gonna do my best
to predict we know a few things that are
coming out early in the year but I have
some thoughts on what's gonna come up so
first of all hear me out on this one the
fifty shades darker soundtrack I'm
actually really excited for we've
already heard taylor swift and zane song
which is really good actually and last
year no matter what you thought about
the movie itself I think this soundtrack
really stood on its own there was a lot
of great music on their old stuff and
new original stuff so I think the new
one could be even bigger and better with
bigger names we I mean the first song
off of it is Taylor shipped and Zane so
I and only get bigger from there so I'm
really excited that movie is out on
februari 10th so look for the soundtrack
to come out maybe a week fryer something
around that time um but speaking of
Taylor Swift I really think she's gonna
release an album this year too yeah
she's way overdue oh yeah she it's been
over two years since 1989 came out of
course she had like world domination in
that time killed it in her pop crossover
and most importantly guys she's fresh
out to breakups on the kind of taylor
beat continuing that a little bit she's
got a really good pal in nashville named
kelsea ballerini i love her i adore her
so much she is i know for a fact working
on her next album fun fact about Kelsey
she released her debut album well over a
year ago I think I don't remember the
date and I should um but she broke a
really cool record she was the first
woman in country music to have her first
three singles go number one that's
really cool it was awesome and I didn't
know that that was a record that didn't
exist already I kind of assumed that
Taylor had shattered is 180 yeah yeah so
that was Kelsey's record that she held
last year also you guys know I love
country I have to give a shout-out to my
girl rae lynn she was on Team Blake on
the voice in season two I know she's got
a new album coming out very soon next
year she's going back out on tour with
Blake and she's one to watch because
she's now on Blake Shelton's record
label
which makes a big difference so I
predict there might be a collaboration I
don't know that for sure but he is
really kind of making it his personal
mission to make her a star on the pop
front of things we're hearing that
Fergie's new album is gonna be called
double Duchess I'm really excited for
that touchless her album the Duchess can
you believe it's been over 10 years I
can because I remember dancing to it in
high school so yeah I'm really so good
yeah panel um but we've heard two songs
of that milf money was that kind of
crazy music video with kim kardashian
and chrissy teigen was a little out
there now she's got life goes on which
gives me kind of big girls don't cry
vibes it's like round two of that phone
um so I'm excited to hear what else
she's got now this is total and complete
speculation I have no information to
really back these up except I i think
these stars are overdue first of all
miley cyrus it's been a minute since
bangers came out I loved that album cuz
we can't stop wrecking ball um so she's
overdue she did release that Miley Cyrus
and her dead who they have a fan yeah
that was in 2015 so still kind of a
while ago but to me that was kind of
like a maybe a passion project somali i
wasn't like i don't know i want a
bangers follow-up so Miley please you
have a season off from the voice give me
some new music oh also Katy Perry we
mentioned her earlier it's been a long
time prism came out in 2013 and since
then I know right she had rise that
Olympic song that came out but there's
no album on that so I'm hoping that
she'll have a full-length also hoping
for a full length from Justin Timberlake
he's been working with Pharrell for over
a year now and he did release can't stop
the feeling from the girls soundtrack
did not work with Pharrell on that one
though she didn't know so this is a
separate project that he and for all
work guys it sounded so much like happy
that I figured that uh I'll have his
hand in it all right infectious yeah in
a word so one thing I Justin Timberlake
did work on that I think a lot of people
didn't notice was he secretly recorded
vocals for Little Big Town song come on
he did work with for all on that
so that was kind of cool and little big
town is releasing an album in February
that's confirmed their album is called
the breaker and bringing it full circle
to the beginning here their new single
called better man was written by who
else but Taylor Swift oh she's so
talented if you pointed lyrics though
innit can we roll a little bit of that
song
and I just miss you in
wish you were
yeah so she sings a lot about you know
the guy not being good enough for her a
lot of people wandering who she's
singing about is it Calvin Harris is it
every man on the planet it could be
she's i will say there was a great
songwriter so i think she can kind of
channel anything whether it's super
personal to her or not and make gold out
of it but a lot of people are wondering
if that phone might be about Calvin so
uh the breaker comes out in February
that's a little big town they're awesome
but I predicted that 2017 is going to be
the year of Taylor Swift to wrap it all
up it makes sense that she would want to
release an album next year we've been
hearing for a while that she's really
wanted to do the Super Bowl gig which of
course is sponsored by Pepsi Taylor
previously had a deal with coca-cola or
she has a deal coca-cola we're hearing
that it's expiring which would line her
up very nicely for a 20-18 super bowl
game so that's my prediction 2017 year
of Taylor bleeding into 2018 oh I like
it
[Music]